enough is enough
the message to tens of millions of
followers today as football stands up to
racism and Premier League players lead a
24-hour social media blackout
the hashtag enough campaign is based on
the fact that players have actually come
to us and said look we're fed up of
what's going on here in terms of online
racist abuse we want someone to do
something about it we want to see the
online service providers actually take
action to actually remove these posts
more swiftly and probably more likely to
actually prevent them getting on there
in the first place top players including
Sterling Delhi and England women's
captain Steph Horton amongst those
who've joined the boycott so they'll be
completely off social media from 9:00
this morning until 9:00 a.m. tomorrow
meaning that their fans won't get any of
their online insights everything from
birthday celebrations to match reaction
and even fashion tips
what really pleases me about this
initiative is that the players are
totally engaged and I'm not just talking
about black players I'm talking about
all players trying to get the social
media platforms and the football bodies
to do more and collectively with this
sort of initiative you'll hope that that
can be achieved this follows a spate of
racist incident in the last few weeks
earlier this month Danny Rose faced
racism from Montenegro fans and on
Tuesday Manchester United's Chris
Smalling was abused on social media
after their Champions League clash in
Barcelona
Liverpool's masala and Manchester City's
Raheem Sterling just some of the others
who've seen the ugly side of the
beautiful game and in the championship
at Millwall a club that's had their own
battles with racism fans fear a day of
silence doesn't go far enough still get
abused anyway right now because
everyone's on social media these days
aren't they everyone's got Instagram
snapchat and what-have-you
yeah I think you'll make a difference by
whoever is going to make a big big
difference I don't know
they've all got loads of followers on
Instagram and social media so yeah
24 hours is long enough no more than
that probably yeah the Union ultimately
wants to put pressure on international
bodies like UEFA and FIFA they know one
day won't stop abuse but this is their
quiet start to silence Singh football's
racists
Alley Fortescue Sky News